マジで中央なことを言いますマジでこれはもう
メインチャンネルに上げてもいいぐらい大事なことを言います偽物についてです
今実は僕の偽物が
あらゆるゲームアプリそして sns
youtube にももうすごい数の偽物の僕がいますマジで
いろんな人がこうなんかコメントとか twitter とかでこう言ってくれるん
ですよこれ始め7これ始めだろうとかこれ偽物これ本物これ本当にはじめ7 f 椅子
ブックはじめからダイレクトメッセージもらったよとこう
いろんなことを公
僕に入ってくれるわけなんですよあのなんでこの動画ではえっと
本物の僕のそのなんだろアカウントを
ここで言いますで今僕から発表する僕が今からいうアカウント以外はすべて偽物です
たとえその偽物が俺は本物だとか言ってても絶対偽物です今から言う奴しか僕はやって
ませんんそれがもう全部偽物と思ってください
本物ポッキーを見せものですいやでも通りでも
本物ならと思って保持するものですよこれどう見ても早めさんどうやってを偽物なん
ですそれにしてもの音が誘導する際とか偽物なんか危ないサイトとかだったりするって
いう情報を聞いたのでマジで皆さん気を付けて下さい今からいうものだけが本物です
はいまずはこちら肇社長のチャンネル youtube のチャンネルですねこれ本物
です
登録者には140万人がいるのでわかりやすいと思いますはい
youtube に専門チャンネルが多いんでそれだとこんなちゃんねる
はじめしゃちょー2ゲーム実況の動画ゲームの動画とか
カードゲームとかまあ
すっごいしょうもない動画とかをアップしている
はじめしゃちょーズってチャンネルですこれにも始めたちょうどはじめチャットつ
でえっともう一個 twitter もやってます twitter はこちらです
うん基礎
えっと肇社長って書いてありますこれが僕のツイッターのアカウントですこれしかない
です
はいもう一個
遊戯王専用のツイッターのアカウントがありますデュエル始めというやつです
twitter この2つですこれ以外はも何もないです本当に何もないです
田治米社長2となっても嘘です
全部嘘でさんとはこの2つだけでなんで youtube 2つに付いた2つでもう一
個
755も一つアカウントがありますはず3冊をの
75このアカウントがあります755も結構偽物が出てて
結構なんかボクっぽい返信の仕方をしてて
工業だなぁと思いつつ
迷惑しておりますまあな午後はあのコース機のアカウントになっているのでおっしゃる
って書いてあるってとても分かりやすいと思います
この五つで基本的に今使っているのはコイツ以外は
多分使ってないよちょっとこの一途でこの5月第4回と使ってませんあとは
すべて偽物だと思ってもらっても構わないです
そうだよね連れでもハグしれないけどそう facebook とかも何もやってない
のであとは全部偽物ということでございます
強いでこういう正
いつものが出るくらい
だっていうちょっと嬉しいことなんですけどもまぁ
迷惑している
こともあるので皆さんぜひ気をつけてもらいたいと思っております
時ダイエット今言ったのに舌ですねこれが全部するものということでございました
今日もおいしい牛乳はいつもとにおいしいでございます
[音楽]